matt tonight
it's a billion dollar jackpot over a
billion dollars actually it's going to
be the second largest in lotto history
and michelle i just want to say it's
been really nice spending time with you
nice working oh cause i'm gonna win oh
no i'm gonna win i'm gonna win
but listen here's how the winner aka me
not you will stack up against
hollywood's rich and famous
your chances of winning let's just say
they are around 1 in 302.5
million if you go for the lump sum
you're going to take home 648 million
bucks
[Music]
tonight's mega millions is right up
there near rihanna who's worth an
estimated 1.3 billion dollars the
journey has been incredible
she spends with style some reported
highlights 38 000 a week on glam 800 a
day for a private chef and 1300 for one
pair of gucci socks
[Applause]
[Music]
you'd have to have more than double the
jackpot for oprah money the media
mogul's worth an estimated 3.5 billion
you start making money and everybody's
like whoa money money i have lived that
myself how is the yacht it looks amazing
oh thank you just last month tiger woods
hit billionaire status according to
forbes he told us all about his 20
million yacht called privacy it turned
out nice we have
we got a chance to basically entertain
our friends and family on the boat but
more importantly we have a set up for a
nice little dive center oh so it's a
dive sensor
whenever we go we can dive anywhere we
want
even more extravagant how about blasting
off at 50 million a trip the billion
dollar lottery winner could go to outer
space 27 times with jeff bezos but can a
billion dollars buy happiness kylie
jenner says the real secret is finding a
sense of purpose if i could give some
advice let's do something that you love
so you just have fun every day and you
love what you do
[Music]